hey really big show coming up a little
bit a little bit of Sullivan there
nobody okay but I wanted to tell you
before that about next Wednesday is
going to be our last livestream of the
year December 18th a big live Christmas
show dress and formal attire they'll be
limited seating for about two three
hundred people there sign up for the
mailing list it's available exclusively
to mug club members it's a variety show
well let me explain this to you three
years ago I was waterboarded as part of
a Christmas telethon then two years ago
I livestream CNN for 16 hours and then
last year I was very sick naturally and
so we decided we don't to do that
anymore but we will do a live Christmas
variety show with musicians and surprise
guests and sketches and Santa that we
will do every year from hereafter and
also raise some money for Christmas
baskets so that's December 18th next
Wednesday sign up for the mailing list
and for details but here's a little bit
of what you missed for those who aren't
in my club icesoft I'm hoarse she can go
back to spread thank you when a lot of
times studios everyone there has a huge
impact in my life except for maybe the
guy that replaced a blow-up doll the
chair feels so empty well
a six-year-old YouTube star bought a
house that in American dollars is
actually close to being with 7.5 million
dollars Wow you can check it out in this
week's episode of actual cribs Wow and I
got to say what YouTube has done to you
has been ridiculous and I'll tell you
I'm in my office right now
I sat down with the CEO of YouTube right
behind us sitting on that couch and went
after her hard for why are you guys
targeting steven crowder the demands are
not coming from both sides evenly it's
the left that is saying censor in
silence crowder I'm not asking you to
silence lefty no at the socialist morons
talk and we'll engage him on
[Music]
this is Fisher versus the University of
Texas question of whether race can be
used as an admissions criteria to u.s.
colleges and universities if the nation
has done something special against the
Negro as we were then called for 240
years the nation must do now something
special for the negro so merit is
dependent upon who counts what is
meritorious
[Music]
all the racist Steven cutter y'all I
would probably punch him if I saw I said
it's not racist and now I'm thinking
maybe it could be a little bit louder
with Crowder studios protected
exclusively by Walter
[Music]
[Music]
I'm not dancing I just ran a
half-marathon did you know you had to
tape your nipples you do yeah I've
shaved this I found that one out the
hard way yeah and I have no more
toenails oh wow I'm kidding I do not run
a half marathon I love how we reduced
marathon to half marathon I like my
favorites the 180 we needed some non
Kenyans to place we have Tim Poole in
the show today of course we have our big
Christmas show next Wednesday live
stream we will be tough well first okay
I have to do this question of the day
want to keep it simple because sometimes
you guys go on and you're little queasy
in the comments section I appreciate it
keep the anti-semitism and the racism
you know to a minimum okay
non-existent not the ones that we see in
the comments section the anti anti me
stuff anti white stuff that's fine
so to word answer how do you identify
politically and do you believe in the
idea of the deep state in other words I
want your comment to be an example
Democrat no or Republican yes which will
be 90% of the comment replies I
understand do you believe do you believe
there's a significant number of people
in these government agencies like the
FBI CIA actively working to undermine
President Trump at nearly every turn
or is it a ridiculous conspiracy theory
because I've seen people's minds
changing on these topics we have Tim
Poole coming up in a little bit we will
be talking about the impeachment
proceedings my half-asian lawyer bill
Richman is here for safety how are you
yes how are you and is his father is in
the audience today a quarter black gear
show me hood pass up doll I don't like
it no one watching does audio wait is
here to cue Marian overlays and Gerald a
how are you sir I'm doing well how are
you alright well what's depending on
what the wine of the day is well it's
it's bubbles right you got to celebrate
its Baron Baron new YouTube's guidelines
when you host your Valkyrie parties I
did you know I haven't watched Valkyrie
in a little while say what's a little
while for you for weeks
Wow I don't know every Friday
to a while so we will be discussing all
of this and more but first let's
celebrate Kwanzaa that was my song and
Arthur's perfect Christmas very early
that was not supposed to be in the song
I was so bad at singing and rapping as
the brain that I listen to the album and
all my verses are gone you suck get
singing thank you very clear fired at
12:00 and black show is fired at 13:00
they said your voice changed what
happens I have low self confidence our
top story of course Greta soon Berg x
2019 Person of the Year this comes from
NBC News a 16 year old climate activists
is the magazine's youngest choice ever
of course many consider Greta to be the
obvious choice so they were some pushing
for who I'm sure is now a very
disappointed whistleblower she's got me
I tried shooting for evidence they give
it to some sweet with the side ponytail
and she's playing hooky getting awesome
school I didn't can talk to my family
under witness protection holiday in and
it's not even Express I'm trying to take
out can sit and plug in I don't get my
full leg daddy uh-huh
how dare you know how you okay how about
that you and your side ponytail and Mike
CD here they don't swing for cables not
even play me well the city Suzanne it
was a you know an axe to grind
Wow yeah I hear a time is Person of the
Year it's a big so you know what listen
congratulations to Greta who will now
take her rightful place among some of
the greatest icons of our time
[Music]
19:41 Franklin D
[Music]
1963 dr. Martin Luther King jr.
2001
39 and 1942 Joseph Stalin 1938 Adolf
2019
[Music]
you know we don't often appreciate that
Hitler was the first social influencer
if anybody would be his today been
Instagram going yes an idol I get my
Zumba I have all the energy because of
my 50 to be redirected with the energy
which gives me jitters of caffeine is a
macho fan yes go to match up for you why
is he Asian nation bill Richman is
laughing so he gets that Asian or I want
to get them there's something about it
bill Richman's laughter that is
contagious it's a very Buddha esque pick
it all up and save it and then I grab
any hold that his hand I grab a little
bit of cardamom and I go that is a
palate cleanser so in 2020 news a new
poll shows that Hillary Clinton will
actually be would overtake Joe Biden as
the Democrats top choice so and I have
to look at this this my pet today
because there's a lot of quotes
regarding the interesting I don't wanna
incorrect so this is also very important
the details according to a recent
Harvard Harris poll respondents who
identified as Democrats heavily favored
Joe Biden when asked which presidential
candidate they preferred but then when
former Secretary of State Hillary
Clinton was added to the mix she came
out on top of all the current candidates
garnering 21% Wow of respondents to
Biden's it said 20% gotta suck for Joe
well it should be noted by the way
because we don't we won't want to put
too much diagnosis was a relatively
small sample size conducted exclusively
with self-identified Democrats when
pulling Wyden to the general electorate
however both candidates did lose a
three-way race to red skull so that was
a big thing it was oh that's close
though yeah he's a strong leader trust
Nate Silver it's a smile look at those
teeth it doesn't mean it's over yet it's
the face of determination and multiple
genome experiments what is it worth
redstone Captain America I have no idea
that of Captain America it burns I don't
know someone's gonna argue in the
comments section and forget the original
question today thanks
so ed smart you guys were absent father
of the kidnapping victim Elizabeth Smart
he's come out today saying I thought
Elizabeth's ordeal was very difficult
but this one is more difficult because
it is not only it not only affected
Elizabeth but my entire family well you
heard it here first
being gay is worse than your child
getting kidnapped wow man you serious
dad's honesty Elizabeth Smart was quoted
as saying my dad's gay this is the worst
thing that's ever happened to me and you
know what here's the family the family
was shocked the only people who were
shocked at this revelation but I get it
sometimes it really sometimes it is hard
to evaluate people especially when
you're the ones closest to them even
hungry
you guys know where Jamal Jamal are you
surprised
[Laughter]
do you get a hint but maybe your friend
is that way the way he talks the way he
dresses the way he carries himself it
all makes you start to wonder is your
friend black well now you can find out
for sure with black dark simply swab the
inside of your friends mouth send us the
sample and in four to six months you'll
get your results now I can use Rachael
for Jordan's without fear thanks black
dark black dark it's the only way 23
minutes to branch a heads up with new
products all the time lifecycle let's go
most failure marks been off there's not
enough market share for candidates
running who want to put down one 1000
24th Cherokee but what we really need is
one that tells you whether the candidate
actually did blackface in the past
what's really more of a questionnaire
yeah hi have you ever been a hypocrite
like to be the prime minister you just
do like a black light to choose your own
path only it all directs you to the high
school newspaper oh that's oh that's
true
see also high school yearbook like you
did a whole year in black okay this is
summer now cuz it's a sad story
obviously a bomb blast in Pakistani moss
killed two and injured fourteen more a
lot of people haven't covered this after
the blast one worshiper was heard saying
sorry girls that was mine but it
actually was was sorry guys that was
mine comes at a tough time for these
lammott recruitment center apparently
people get a little bit touchy when you
start joking about terrorist bombings I
don't care blast them at a tough time
for the Islamic recruitment centers they
just started running their new ad
campaign titled Islam growing at an
explosive rate the heelflip icescape
goofy stuff to be goofy i don't think
you can be left-handed there is it i get
it you just we're gonna get to the
impeachment proceedings and all of that
I don't want to yet like I just want I
don't want to wake up you ever just not
want to wake it so because you're
depressed or suicidal you just go oh I
gotta watch this on TV shifts going to
appear again salons gonna write an
article
YouTube's gonna change their guidelines
so we can't critique it and then the
deep state thing I don't know anyway the
point is I want to die if someone wants
to help me and here's the thing if ever
I word I never if ever I were to take
myself out it would never be with a
Walther no just because I would never
want to take the sponsorship razorblades
I don't know I mean if in it would never
be with a Walther I do everything
happened with gusto here's a story about
a duck named Dave who had this is a true
story actually of his penis removed
after being overly amorous with the
ladies
it comes from the mirror the owner of
the duck was forced to intervene after
the little guy injured himself having
sex with the female companions up to ten
times a day just favorite duck the owner
also intent by the way signed a book
deal for his upcoming autobiography
he titled how to rape farm animals and
blame it on your pet duck so that's
pretty yeah it's more of an
instructional really publisher from
O'Jays if I did it you know pretty much
yes instruction manual this one just
says I am it and this is sad this next
story is said a model miss Miami I don't
want to do it I don't want to talk we
have to a model miss Miami she may need
her 60-inch butt amputated after getting
illegal butt injections the loss this
comes from the New York Post she told a
reality show she wanted less junk in the
trunk but says and I quote amputate the
whole booty on not amputating butts you
know what listen is there's something we
need to talk about if you make butt
injections illegal then we'll have
nothing but back-alley butt injections
performed by Sir mix-a-lot okay do we
need to have legal butt injections rare
safely rare these are the critical
issues of our time especially Armenians
over in Kazakhstan come on we're gonna
act like this is already been over in
Kazakhstan actually this is a it's close
enough in that it is also a place I
don't yearn to visit a Kazakhstan
bodybuilder is set to marry his sex
robot so yeah the man says that his
relationship with Margo the doll is very
much taken seriously this isn't the
article despite admitting that they have
arguments the occasional arguments
despite the arguments it's still a
healthy relationship that's good to hear
the arguments included by the way the
symmetry of his bicep the tricep ratio
the best strategy to add math to his
calves and whether or not a sex robot is
really convincing anyone that he's not
gay I mean she wins
that relationships and entertainment no
it's just wd-40 gosh pop an
instructional DVD in swat salary every
now and a half like blow-up dolls put it
on the roof expands your minds in
entertainment news singer Ricky Martin
welcomed a son with his husband Juan
Yosef so congratulations to Ricky Martin
and he said he's thrilled was quoted as
saying there is nothing as beautiful as
the face of a newborn baby staring back
at you except perhaps a hot hairy ass he
said oh so glad there's nothing over the
baby was voters say this is the worst
thing that's ever happened to me -
Stephen Merchant
finally before we get to impeachment
this week a group of New Yorkers slept
in Times Square to raise funds for
homeless charity a spokesman for the
group was quoted as saying hey stop
raping me it never works Bob much honor
request really no no no it's not this
not very effective telling you by the
way actually here we have an interview I
think do we we have an interview with
one of the homeless men in question from
this event
[Music]
you just give it to me in cash what are
you gonna spend on that my tuft hmm well
there you have it folks perhaps we will
never know what happened that night in
the tent
well let's say that we spent far too
much fur on the field oh it's recording
all the way to New York the
misappropriation of my funds riveting
since I signed the front of checks here
I should look at those more often into
this is this all confirmed the idea of
the deep state if you've been following
an impeachment okay let's start with
this this week the Justice Department
the Inspector Justice Department
inspector the Justice Department
Inspector General sorry Michael Horowitz
so many vowels lots of titles what's
going on release a report looking in the
FBI's investigation of President Trump's
campaign okay he was questioned about
the report in a Senate hearing yesterday
let's see that real quick the inspector
general found that when the FBI secretly
opened an investigation into possible
Russian influence of the Trump campaign
in July 2016 it followed the launching
that kind of case the report says the
FBI's court application made statements
about steel that were quote inaccurate
incomplete and unsupported over selling
his value as a source and glossing over
the fact that many claims he made were
not checking out yeah
claims some mistakes that's a funny word
if you listen to some of the leftist
shows and I've been listening to
obviously the Young Turks pod save
America or reading up at Vox and so on
they're gonna try and spin this as some
minor procedural errors made by
low-level FBI employees that's kind of
the story that's been going out there
and I encourage you to go and read and
watch further left sources because that
is kind of a narrative that they've sent
it just sound familiar to anybody when
conservatives were targeted by the IRS
so it's low-level people it was a
mistake right we didn't do this which by
the way also lends itself to defect that
civil libertarians and a lot of
Republicans always had a problem with
the abuses of FISA right we've if you
could if you could search out if we
could search which words we've used in
this program we've talked about Barack
Obama and Phi's up several times like I
do think it's important to be consistent
here let's see now have you been even
following it here yes yeah well it and I
would say just to put it in context
right you know that the general audience
isn't following the Canali
you'll standards and bases to do this
but just let's put this in normal terms
if you've watched any show where there's
some backroom shenanigans and someone
gives some fake evidence to a judge to
get a wiretap or do other things like
that this is exactly what they're saying
happened here
you had to falsify information to clear
the hurdles do get extraordinary law
enforcement remedies because you didn't
actually have the evidence to grade and
yes and that is and that's why I think
the intellectual honesty of the report
is that this is a serious failure I mean
this is ultimately unconstitutional yes
and we'll go let's go through that step
by step let's go through the series of
mistakes the FBI made even if maybe the
Inspector General can't detect any
pattern that might point to a motive
maybe we can so we would like to
introduce this new segment a calls could
it all be an accident
[Applause]
boy that was out of tenants oh really
man I will take conspiracy theories for
five hundred and ensuring that I am
removed from the platform let's stop
with this this there's a couple of
claims let's go through the claims one
of the claims that Comey and others were
exonerated Democrats left-wing media
they were quick to say that the IG
report exonerated James Comey right we
have an overlay here the truth is that
the Inspector General said the report
did nothing even close to that
the former FBI director James Comey said
this week and that your report
vindicates him is that a fair assessment
of your report I you know I think the
activities we found here don't indicate
anybody who touched this yeah no they
have a problem with reports here what's
going on like the bar thing with no
collusion there now they didn't say that
and this didn't say something and
they're saying it says something well
over the believe bar is an example of
collusion at the corruption at the
highest level as opposed to dozens of
high-level employees at the FBI who
systematically worked to undermine our
presidency just be just be sure that you
understand you won't have it straight I
want to make sure thank you another
claim which i think is you guys may
remember this but there were a lot of
claims made and it's kind of silly that
we have to go back to this but this is
actually very important because of I
don't know if this is effectively
falsified we'll get some information
that to me I'm not I'm not a lawyer we
have a lawyer seems falsified but the
context of this seems at the very least
deliberately misleading some claims that
people made regarding the infamous
Russian peeing tape oh boy when you told
him the contents of the steel dossier
did you get the impression was the first
time he'd ever heard those allegations
yes and I didn't give him the briefing
on the whole steel dossier my assignment
was to brief him on a small part of it
that was salacious and personal and my
sense was I didn't get a sense that he
knew about those why include that
salacious part if it was something that
you thought was you know not that
necessary to the investigation or did
you think it was important then he knew
we thought it was important that he knew
and I say we meaning all the
intelligence Chiefs that put together
the intelligence community assessment we
thought it was
that he know because we knew and we
don't be holding that back from the new
president and you believe his denial I
honestly never thought these words would
come out of my mouth but I don't know
whether the current president states
with his prostitutes peeing on each
other in Moscow in 2013 it's possible
but I don't know and by the way after
that interview Chuck Todd's goatee
cocooned into a butterfly and flew away
[Laughter]
summarize their Comey was saying that
was his duty to brief the president
about the P tape and then claims that
very he thought it very well may have
been true let me explain this very
clearly the FBI not only knew that the
story had zero corroboration they knew
that it was in fact a joke the FBI
interviewed Steele source and asked him
to corroborate the story but the source
and I have a quote here explained that
his or her information came from
word-of-mouth and hearsay
another quote conversation that he or
she had with friends over beers and that
some of the information such as
allegations about Trump's sexual
activities were statements he or she
heard made in Jess oh my gosh think of
that for a second all you needed to do
was make a joke and if it were from if
it reflected badly enough on President
Trump the FBI would purposefully
misrepresent it as though it was a
credible allegation all the way up to
the director of the entire FBI who would
then brief the President himself on it
half-asian we're bill Richman what kind
of territory are we in there well
especially when you get that they leaked
that information in the same false spin
you can see it's clearly an attempt to
not only get past the normal standards
that you would have in you know
triggering law enforcement wiretapping
and other type of information or other
types of investigative tools but clearly
an attempt not to try and get to the
truth right if you really were trying to
get to the truth you would have gone to
the quote to the source and ask the
source so here's the question that
ultimately comes down to did you forget
to go check with the source
did you know you weren't checking with
the source or did you actually check
with the source but not bother to
provide that information and the range
of misdeeds there runs from grossly
negligent in your duties as a law
enforcement agency and considering one
of the top law enforcement agencies to
direct violation of your duties yeah
knowing violation of your duty and you
know I will say this the more
information that comes out the worse it
is for Democrats that insist
through linear examples it is we've
often said like there's probably a
kernel of truth to it I thought maybe
there were Russian prostitutes peeing in
a in a Trump Hotel and he knew about it
and said you know they like the waters
would something like that turns out it
was entirely made up from a joke the
truth is worse than the way I'd see
scraping the bottom of the barrel but
it's a bottomless barrel you're just
like your your way down into the dirt
and you're looking up far you know this
is so well on the show billions you'd go
to jail for this conduct this is true
yeah also Paul Giamatti is goatee would
cocoon into a butterfly
no that was a moth my jawline Jimmy okay
another play that they make the steel
dossier wasn't central to the FISA
warrant oh no I'm sorry before that I
need to tell people right hit the
notification bail because subscriptions
don't mean a whole lot but do subscribe
to the channel we have a new video
you've been letting me say this wrong
this whole time guys 9:00 Eastern it's
not an easter it doesn't matter either
way
join up at Mudd Club bladder with hunter
calm flush mug club that's where you get
all of the extra content some shows even
hosted by me half a similar bill
Richmond where's the whole blaze catalog
and next week Wednesday big live
Christmas show it'll be a live stream
with a discount we'll be raising money
for Christmas baskets okay let's move on
here another claim this is important
because you're gonna hear this from The
Young Turks are going to hear this from
all these left sources MSNBC that the
steel dossier wasn't central to the FISA
warrant okay in case you've forgotten
maybe you recall that Devon Nunez the
memo claims the steel dossier was an
essential part of the evidence used to
begin the FBI spying on Trump's campaign
the Democrats claimed that this was
absolutely not true the deputy director
of the FBI
McCabe testified before your committee
in December of 2017 that no surveillance
warrant no FISA Court to this Weiser
court would have been sought without the
steel dossier information is that true
that's a not what the director McCabe
McCabe actually said well I can't go
into the details of what he said
essentially his argument was we look at
this as a complete hole all the part
of the application are important okay so
of course the entire leftist made they
piled on as well claim Anil dossier was
only a small part of the evidence death
definitely not essential
non-essential it's funny here's the
truth not only to the IG report find
that the dossier played a sent I want to
read this as a quote central and people
go you can't get off it today I am
making sure that I am on this iPad
because I don't want to get this wrong
do it when you're dealing with the FBI
kind of scary anything they can make the
mistakes not you found the dossier
played a central and essential role in
the FISA application when it came to
Carter pages by the way alleged Russia
collusion the steel dossier was the
entire basis it was it wasn't a small
basis it wasn't a portion it was the
only basis there was no other basis I
mean do they really expect people to buy
into this it's a convenient lie for them
to be now that they have the FISA
warrants and now that we're down the
road to be like oh no that didn't matter
at all we didn't base it on that like
right is anybody really buying that
looking back at a bill like I mean it
legally is anybody gonna buy this and
say no that wasn't a part of the deal
well I think part of the core part of
the question here is whether or not
anyone's gonna hold a legal standard to
you know Schiff and the others who have
tried to say at one point oh look at how
important this dossier is oh no no
actually no no it wasn't important right
and yeah we we really didn't put any
stock into it but that's actually one of
the benefits here of our 24-hour news
cycle and kind of the constant way that
everyone's been pushing the questions
because on record time and time again
Schiff and the others who have been
pushing this the the what was happening
before right are being caught by their
own words and so ultimately whether or
not you know Congress takes action or
the DOJ takes action about those who
push this who got these FISA warrants
illegally essentially that's what it's
you you can falsify the evidence to
provide the standards to get law
enforcement tools you have committed a
crime yeah and so whether or not they're
going to be you know held accountable is
a question but really it's the voters
right
it is the voters and by the way I don't
see they're gonna be calls on it from
the media that's the problem of course
they're gonna call it by this show I
don't really think they care and that's
way people want to remove this show yeah
good luck okay here's another claim that
the Obama administration didn't use
Adashi eight all this this came out this
week that they didn't use it a C at all
in their intelligence assessment here
you go listen do you know if the bureau
ever relied on the steel dossier is
as part of any court filings I like
anybody 320 petitioners bleeding I have
no awareness at all
complete utterly unaware did the CIA
rely on it no one IO because we we did
it wasn't part of the corpus of
intelligence information that we had it
was not in any way used as a basis for
the intelligent assessment that was done
it was it was not and by the way that
they didn't try it out Gerald Ford's
corpse that CIA director John Brennan in
case you didn't know yeah I'm gonna sum
up his answer may be no Jill Ford you
know from Grand Rapids Michigan where
look for a long time there's the Grand
Rapids Gerald Ford museums in Grand
Rapids who knows Jerald name is
fantastic it's shaped like a pizza slice
so it looks really big from the front
it's a joke for museum I went in now
about halfway through there's random
Elvis exhibits like hey here's the king
of rock'n'roll Museum and then there's a
gift shop but they're selling like
Velociraptor pillows so that was
intelligent as CIA director John Brennan
he was saying that they didn't even know
about the steel dossier right the Obama
ministration that this is important to
know they all knew about the steel
dossier there was actually included as
an appendix in the assessment itself not
only do they give the steel dossier
credit you practically wrote the
foreword even further than that by the
way Comey McCabe fought to have it
playing even more central role in the
assessment proactively so I want to be
clear I mean I don't know at what point
lying yeah constitutes a crime yeah but
this I want you to research the sources
for yourself ok we have to we have to
cycle through this because we have Tim
Poole coming up pretty quick to talk
about any limited policies
here's another claim they make up a FISA
warrant was obtained completely honestly
on the up anon a total confidence that
the FISA process was followed and that
the entire case was handled
thoughtful responsible way by DOJ and
the FBI I think the notion that Pfizer
was abused here is nonsense okay so this
is pretty important and and let me know
if it's a little confusing and maybe
Bill you can help clarify because it's
confusing for me sometimes when I work
in this industry
the FBI created fraudulent evidence to
obtain the one I know bill honker
because I'm making a claim here I
believe that I can make that claim and
substantiate it just pause or if you
don't have the time fast forward four
seconds Carter page k was actually
acting as an informant for the CIA
during these Russian meetings k the FBI
knew that right so to be clear the FBI
omitted that information from the FISA
applications and even used Carter's
connection to those Russian contacts as
evidence against him think of that for a
second they knew so it's like okay go
out there you're gonna have contact
you're gonna be informant with the
Russians and then afterwards gonna hang
you out to the dry and say look what the
Russians yeah it's like taking Donnie
Brasco and saying sorry you're Cootes
with the mob you're arrested now right
do you think I'm a rat under yes if Al
Pacino leaves his cross in the top
drawer that means he's going out alone
to die let him go
powerful scene powerful thing of that
done
that's when Al Pacino wasn't playing an
Al Pacino character that's just when he
was actually good the recent movie of Al
Pacino did you see but you know play
Jimmy Hoffa know it is the most
offensively bad performance he goes from
trying he's sitting and talking like
this trying to do a Midwestern accent he
and then he goes to you movie going back
this way to Scarface I don't know it's
like I drew my inspiration from Jimmy
Hoffa sounds like Bernie almost so
here's why I am saying this definitively
that they create that they falsified
information you're the FBI emailed the
CIA to check if Paige was working with
him okay they confirmed that Paige was a
source that it that Paige was a source
but an FBI lawyer and then I want to go
to my lawyer he's a lawyer
an FBI lawyer actually altered the text
of the email to say he was
not a source to be clear okay it said
was a source initial an FBI lawyer
change the text to read Mathis or not a
source by the way lawyer now under
criminal investigation no how does that
go half-asian lawyer but can I make the
claim that that is falsifying evidence
changing the word yes - no I mean yes
all of you here again here again is the
thing is how are they going to try and
spin this and say you know oh it was
just a mistake oh you know just a
low-level delano for the FBI hit the
delete button for s.a.w and then for
some i accidentally typed in n OT i
don't know i spilled coffee in the
keyboard that's the last time I use a
Dell gateway I mean only gateway under
criminal investigation and I understand
the optics there's the court of public
opinion but this is a lot this is a lie
this seems to be something that could be
prosecuted these are the types of things
where you know we call it the fruit of
the poisonous tree as a legal term right
if you in in the common parlance of like
the Fourth Amendment and other
constitutional issues you have to
establish that if early in the chain of
creating evidence or taking certain
action by the government the government
takes wrong action right and the rest of
the information that comes from that the
fruit of the poisonous tree is now
poisoned as well right painted and here
when you when you look at Comey Comey
understood the problem with that that's
why back in December 2018 he's saying no
no no don't worry the tree is not
poisoned everything's great we
fertilized it with great stuff except
they fertilized it with [ __ ] right
that's the problem
and then Eve tried to eat from it
terrible still angry about that unless
you were to write a biography on a Dell
okay since you can't this is also
something else cuz we have to get going
people say you know if you can't say
something better than the guy you said
it before you plagiarism the good thing
is as a host of a late-night show it's
not considered plagiarizing when I just
run a clip so let's just hear senator
Ted Cruz sum this up perfectly a lawyer
at the FBI creates fraudulent evidence
alters an email that is in turn used as
the
basis for a sworn statement to the court
that the court relies on am i stating
that accurately that's correct
that is what occurred hmm that seems
pretty damning yes I have a question
like at some point you know we talked
about public trust a lot yeah but with
the tax thing when they were saying it's
not a tax it's not a penalty for the
health care deal that they were doing
there was no penalty for that they
actually went to the Supreme Court
argued against themselves right and
nothing happened this on the other hand
like you said Bill like there's their
legal ramifications or very well should
be for them lying to get this evidence
into court right to get the FISA
warrants and then daguan at what point
does the public say I just don't trust
any the FBI the IRS Congress everybody
we always say I don't trust anybody who
do you go to now how do you go to for
example if the FBI and CIA if they but
here's here's the thing I want to say
there there are organizations and I and
I know people in the FBI and I've spoken
directly with Shore and are dedicated to
the idea that the FBI is nonpartisan and
regardless of the party so so when
people say you know I think this is the
issue where people take this and say
that deep state is a conspiracy that
makes it crazy but when you look at the
core of it the nugget of truth is are
there individuals within large
organizations that are seeking to take
every benefit of the doubt against the
President and in oftentimes willing to
nudge over the line change a few words
do a few things that snowball into
something very bad from a public PR
perspective or something false in order
to get it so do I believe that there's
some wide-ranging conspiracy with
thousands of individuals with the FBI no
I don't think so I think that day to day
people who are there and these
organizations right are working to do
good by the American people
it's these few individuals that need to
be investigated deeply who weren't
trying to shift using the power they
have to change a few emails to leak a
few bits of information to withhold a
little bit of key data in order to
create a vision of what they want in
order to impact the president but not
low-level people you know that's how
we're full people about it the more
powerful they are you don't need 20
powerful people to make a big impact
exactly not only need one powerful
person to send one email that's altered
well especially with the complicit media
you only need one powerful person the
FBI who knows that the Russian peeing
prostitute bit is a joke
get to Chuck Todd caterpillar mouth and
he goes we're gonna run with this it
only requires one person yeah this is
unprecedented though this is
unprecedented to have these people in
these positions of power over as you've
said other good Americans who want to
serve the country courting these bureaus
yeah in these wings of our of our
federal government - yes obviously one
extent another depending on which
division we're talking about right now
this is unprecedent four people wheeling
that kind of power to be complicit with
the media who don't care to do any
fact-checking right it's hard for us to
fact-check their claims because they
never lists them right that's why we try
to lose anywhere if I'm not mistaken I
think we have one more clip right okay
let's go to one last clip and then go
there is such a range of conduct here
that is inexplicable and the answers we
got were not satisfactory that we're
left trying to understand how could all
these errors have occurred over a
nine-month period or so among three
teams handpicked Hyatt one of the
highest profile from at the highest
profile case in the FBI going to the
very top of the organization evolving a
presidential campaign that is a great
question and that's why it begs could
this all be an accident how could these
inexplicable errors or at least they
haven't been explained yet all occur
going up to the very top of the
organization was it just a sloppy
investigation or do all of these errors
it could just be a sloppy investigation
except when you account for the fact
here that all the errors tilt in a
certain direction one that's anti
President Trump can you let me ask you
this can you find anything to the
contrary in the last six months do you
ever get like you were to go back to
your saying remember the outrage over
bars review of the Moller report people
demanded that he be ousted for his
conclude and obtained from the totality
of information available they saw that
his corruption at the highest level
possible but what about all of these
missteps or sometimes deliberate
inaccuracies in the most powerful
bureaus of government nothing and again
I think what's most important years
every time we get more information
it gets worse for the Democrats right
now in this hall these impeachment
proceedings that's why I think they're
handing Donald Trump the election I wish
this weren't going on because I think it
makes a mockery of our of our entire not
only judicial system but the entire
system of American government
Schoolhouse Rock should be
rolling over in its grave right now this
is absolutely unreal to me but like you
talked about with the IRS investigating
people the IRS being used as a tool from
Barack Obama to audit conservatives now
here's one thing to that I think because
you can audit a ham sandwich right
that's the old kind of adage people say
you can audit a ham sandwich and find
something right that's kind of true they
just there was a story someone just lost
his home because he was eight dollars on
their own property taxes right that's
scary to everybody where you go well
there's a certain amount of power where
the government can find something that
you've done wrong yeah if you're white
this is scary though because if they
don't find something that you've done
wrong they will make it up whether it's
Russian pissing prostitutes or changing
from did know about the steel dossier to
did not know about the steel dossier
this is gone beyond someone making a
mistake and a political enemy
capitalizing on it this has gone to the
most powerful wings of government
arguably in Washington DC now
deliberately fabricating or misleading
investigations for reasons of political
expediency it is terrifying and it sets
a terrifying precedent that we should
all be concerned about now speaking of
terrifying Tim Poole is coming up come
on easy about the Hat me too
more so YouTube's policies
[Music]
dart was being great
mr. Duncan this spa what did you do on
November 8th bolt wide I've been
watching CNN all morning and I'm going
to do it for 16 hours
[Music]
[Music]
Hey hey guys so we got an idea a bright
idea
lay it on with a commercial for black
rifle coffee come we gonna show
everybody how good the coffee is but
beating your black ass yeah don't be so
good
you're gonna forgive we just beat your
ass I start I don't know come on hook up
the brains of that ideal yeah go come on
man you could be the hero I'm a
wholly-owned back what if he punches you
in the stomach no I'm a no I don't think
any of this is necessary but it's not
gonna stress well we can we can run it
by Stephen but I don't think he's gonna
be into it okay yes sure trust me yeah
he's right Dennis glass yeah no that was
lovely so go right now - black rifle
coffee calm / crowd or enter the promo
code Crowder you'll receive 20% off your
first order listen black rifle coffee is
a veteran owned company and they
actually do a lot of good work for
veterans it's not just lip service and
that's all great ok I understand it that
being said I'm pretty persnickety about
my coffee maybe I'll do some coffee
videos in the future I'm pretty nerdy I
weigh it out
I do espresso I do arrow press anyone
out there you tell me your favorite
method of making coffee if it sucked I
would have nothing to do with it their
coffee is pretty damn good
I really like the vintage Rose it's the
green bag with them can I say that do
they have it I want to make okay black
rifle if you're watching don't sell all
of it save some of it that's been my
favorite row so black rifle coffee coms
flash Crowder they have the best coffee
and the best mission of coffee companies
out there
don't buy Maxwell House cuz you be a
dick
[Music]
all right our I don't know what this was
this would be a horrible way to shoot do
you guys watch the radio Gatling gun
it's very cool you're actually just like
Boop when you breathe at the range how
much I sight Jenny could you imagine
trying to hit a target like this
yeah they pull you off your luck sir
that's from the range the sideways but
there's no way to do this accurately so
our next guest you know him and I mean
most of you love everyone loves anyone
loves every guest I should stop saying
that you know I'm some of you like him
you can take him or leave him you follow
him on the YouTube at YouTube that book
last Tim cast he has several very
popular channels and he also before and
he was correcting me he has something
and he's been working through it
he had a ulceration due to anus I'm not
entirely sure Tim Poole is here and you
sound like death what happened with your
voice box uh well my voice is just dying
because I work every single day if no
days off right you talk a lot and I do
yeah
but but but thank you for letting
everyone know about my dental work oh
I'm sorry I thought I didn't know that
was in confidence he has a campus tour
ladies and gentlemen he brushed his
teeth of aim I had a root canal
and I got I got lucky and the anesthetic
resulted in an ulceration mmm it just
made my mouth hurts no that is terrible
I bet through my lip one time from
jujitsu and then it turned into a really
really really bad canker sore so
Congress was are a microscopic kind of
abrasions and then it got really bad but
when you say alteration ulceration it
makes me think of Vincent Price and the
house Cooper elementals this is the
brown recluses he causes his bite causes
creeping operations of the skin that's
in the album from who haven't heard
welcome to my nightmare that's my only
familiarity with the word ulceration Tim
Poole everyone please follow you
released videos this week regarding the
new YouTube guidelines I I don't want
you to speak out of turn it also explain
to people who don't know kind of let
them in and what's been going on because
you've been in the loop in Silicon
Valley and with people at Butte to
Google these companies a long time the
rules are arbitrary they'll value
no reason there you go hey hi so as
alterations have really lend themselves
to brevity it hurts too much so the new
rule is basically your fault thanks for
being snarky with other youtubers but no
it probably does I got it I guess a
obviously they're responding to what
happened with you and cross maza
and the first first most important thing
I think all of your fans recognized they
said you broke no rules they punish you
anyway right I think the new rules are
putting out a completely pointless if
that's what they're gonna do and they've
done it before and they'll do it again
and they've done to me and they
retroactively lecto actively apply rules
to ban channels we get it we get it
it makes no it's pointless yeah for the
sake for the sake of clarity okay what
they're saying now is veiled threats or
like animating some kind of violent
activity directed at somebody is AB
animal offense or guideline strike but
the most alarming is that they're saying
repeated harassing behavior that doesn't
violate the rules could constitute
suspension from the YouTube Partner
Program and it could result in guideline
strikes and eventual you know
termination they're basically saying
what you like an at reply when you put
it like that well so so what happened
with you and Carlos is your ass won't
say the name please so here's the thing
you can criticize people right but
apparently they're saying if you
criticize someone too often right that
could be harassment and you might you if
the rules specifically state what they
put out you are not breaking the rule
but you're butting up against it hmm so
it's like I'll tell you what man I don't
understand that as a rule it's like in a
pools like no running next to the pool
but jogging maybe well another say
they're saying right right it's like no
running brisk walking is okay but if you
brisk walk more than enough then we
arbitrarily decide then we're gonna tell
you you
running and you know that's bad so
you're bad and then you say wait a
second you guys have a pool I say no we
don't we're just putting this out for
future reference I'll let some people in
on a big secret right I know a lot of
people at Google I've known a lot of
people for a long time mm-hmm back back
in like 2011 I had to Google people
reach out to me because of the live
stream work I was doing I've actually
consulted Google dozens of times they
have liked me a lot we'll see how this
goes in the future but you know they've
given I've had like four pairs of Google
glass they I even had someone from
Google send me a cutting-edge ipod touch
back in the day like wow that's all I
know some people there I have respect
for and I'll tell you what I think is
happening based on what they've told me
going back to 20 did it come with that
YouTube album sorry you too yeah yeah
the one that I know I put on every time
of course it did oh that was a bad day
for everyone who was using iPhones we
were loyal for years only to get hello
no no no sorry it was it was it was
right around the time they were phasing
out the iPods anyway right but I hate I
was I was flattered it was a YouTube I
pod and I got like a thing and a thank
you note and these are these are good
people I'm I think they're good people
and some of them have left and probably
for some obvious reasons you know things
have been changing a bit but back in the
day was it back down 2013 I was told by
someone at Google that they were that
they felt Netflix was displacing them
and that's what their concern was and
what they were targeting hmm I said
that's not true your market is not
Netflix your market is a community it's
individuals but they don't see it that
way and they never have so I think right
if I was gonna make a long a bet for the
long term but what's gonna happen you
look back at the data November 2010 the
top youtubers 80% were homegrown
personalities started on YouTube got
famous yeah
today around 20% and they're slowly
replacing the top channels and it's not
necessarily on purpose obviously if you
know Taylor Swift is now interested
she's gonna get millions of subs
something you do about it of course but
YouTube's changing the rules in ways
that will negatively impact a lot of
homegrown behavior and content styles we
already saw one guy famous youtuber this
morning had a video taken down because
it was bullying when in reality it's
like snarky comedic you know roasting is
this the video about I think we have
enough about Leafly from idubbbz
yeah yeah because he was us and he
specifically said yeah he specifically
was addressing a guy named leafy I'm not
super familiar with all youtubers but I
do know him he was specifically
addressing leaf leaf or making fun of an
autistic person yeah and so then he went
full bore and ironically bullied this
other youtuber who was bullying people
with disabilities and the one who was
bullying the disability bullier had his
video removed do I have that correct
I fed its leafy and I think you got it
yes no I gotta be honest you know I know
of them peripherally as well and I like
somebody who files their content but the
way it was framed was it's a bullying
video and YouTube gone so so so here's
another thing about about the rules that
I find worrying
I mean first of all like I said rules
don't matter you know if they're gonna
ban you they're gonna ban you right but
a veiled or implied threat what if I
said oh man you better be careful around
those ante foot people man if you wear a
trump hat they're gonna come and don't
mess you up you know what I mean and
they're gonna claim that I'm threatening
you by saying that if I say like hey I'm
warning you man
you got to be careful when you do that
someone might come and hurt you ring I'm
not look you know so sometimes a warning
can be a veiled threat that's how they
so yeah the rules are arbitrary
if the usual things in a banner YouTube
wants to be Google's version of Netflix
you got Apple the new streaming service
you've got Hulu and and what does Google
have YouTube so they have a bunch of
what what they would view as like not
top-tier high-profile celebrities right
it's obvious when Jimmy Kimmel gets in
the trending tab and you don't for
instance yeah and Jimmy Kimmel can talk
about things that we would get banned
for talking about right so we get it
yeah no that's absolutely true and I
think it also by the way is kind of sad
because this is something that I had to
sort of connect with and I'm sure you
have as well younger people who watch
this show and our biggest demographic on
this show is I don't exactly know how
they break down but like the bulk is
between 18 and 35 between 18 and 35 then
our second biggest demographic is
between 35 and 45 and then I think after
that it's like the 13 to 18 year olds so
which is the exact sort of reverse
mirror of like Fox News your most
conservative content and when I meet
young people who are familiar with the
show it's very different a lot of older
people they mean like a like oh yeah I
love your videos young people they see
youtubers as movie stars to them that is
a big show more young people wanted to
be youtubers than actors and to me sort
of let's disregard this whole idea of
the censorship or the culture of
intimidation for a second to me that is
undervaluing your greatest asset as this
entire generation looks to these people
as the most important content creators
they would care more about someone like
PewDiePie than a George Lucas I'd be
more impressed yeah yeah so YouTube is
here's my bet my bet is in the long term
the rules will continually be built to
favor top tier multi-million dollar
studios it's not just the rules notes
the whole structure it's the algorithm
you want to know why I work
every single day with no day off because
your parties you yes what are you
thinking it's just great full night it's
because the algorithm favors those who
produce the most right and so this
benefits big production studios who can
crank out you know half an hour TV show
every day but not you know most
youtubers will spend a week on a video
right because I do you know off-the-cuff
political commentary it's really easy
for me to record a video on my thoughts
yeah they hate that it's not what
YouTube wanted this algorithm to produce
right they thought if we make an
algorithm that benefits daily long-form
content we're gonna get the mandalorian
we're gonna get Game of Thrones instead
they got dude in his bedroom ranting
about the Democrats yeah so they can't
just get rid of everybody it is a big
portion of the platform right so I think
the rules are slowly being tweaked to
make it harder and harder until people
burn out give up or get banned and
that's actually some of the people are
studying now and and I will say this a
lot of people go at all
oh you're complaining you know YouTube
burnout is not right it's a new
phenomenon from not just YouTube but
social media people who work on social
media or social media sort of figure I
guess you would say political so what do
you call the public figures not
figureheads but people who are a big on
social media now it's a new class of
performer
but typically speaking performers did
not have to cut a bunch of content every
single day Tom Cruise goes to Prague
shoots a film for four or five month
around Fenig runs around a whole lot
maybe fractures an ankle because he had
his bird bones and then after that he
gets a nice long break and now they're
studying this this idea of you know
YouTube burnout and this is because
people cannot sustain it independent
content creators and that's one thing
too
you know we've done the show a lot of
people's like I don't know how you do it
this is why mug club is important it's
how we sustain it because we have 15
people here on staff
the reason the quality the production
value is is good is because we invested
first kind of planning for this going
this is the way I thought always thought
it was going it's expensive and it
requires a lot of work from a lot of
people most people can't compete if
they're coming up right now and don't
have something like that yet it's it's
scary up yeah but I'll tell you what man
for me maybe it's cuz you mentioned I'm
partying
you are I'm just saying if if YouTube
you know I I don't necessarily believe
that every change is intentionally like
we're going to destroy you know Tim
Poole and the political people right but
I think for me I'm gonna run on this
treadmill until my feet are bloody I'm
I'm not gonna stop so I I record six
segments per day it's about an hour and
a half of content it's not a Ben Shapiro
does like three hours
he's got me you know yeah isn't a radio
and that's you know yours talking and
then someone sells an ad for catheters
but that's basically what I do you know
I pull up articles I comment and I get
my shots on them so yeah what most
people wouldn't want your workload and I
will says too about like for me what I
always used to really be upset about I
wasn't as naturally talented I was like
man I got to work three times as hard
and I realize that was kind of my skill
set my talent was that I was willing to
work longer and harder and that's
something that you do as well - I mean I
know obviously you're you're a smart guy
and you're entertaining so people want
to watch you but that is a skill set
that is valuable that being said when
people go like oh I wish I could be paid
to talk to a camera well do you wish you
could be paid for a 15 hour day for five
years of your life without any breaks
because I know that's what Tim Poole
goes through in almost every top YouTube
creator unless they had a viral video
about cats there's an exception for
every rule nothing we do will ever top
it nothing we do will ever top turtle
humping a work boot and we accept that
I'll throw in some good little politics
here I think one of the things that
separates me from like your average
leftist is that I recognize the
importance of grit there's a TED talk
from this teacher and they actually test
the controlled for factors like
intelligence race gender income and they
found the only thing that guaranteed
success was perseverance your
willingness to not give up so that to me
you know when you when you ignore that
fact you create this world of oppression
where the only reason you failed is
because the color of your skin not true
at all
it may be harder it may be easier who
knows obviously I do who gets a million
dollar loan from his dad will have an
easier go of starting a real estate
business than a guy who grew up in the
gutter but the only reason you're gonna
succeed is because you actually refused
to give up right
no I think that's true and I and I I
know that you can't say this about
yourself but I I've talked with you
quite a few times out there and I know
that
Paul has an unbelievable work ethic and
listen this whole industry is littered
with the corpses of people who couldn't
keep it up or refused to keep it up
someone like you does I appreciate that
I respect that about you and I'm not
even gonna do a web extended today
because I know your voice is very hoarse
start using start using Sensodyne my
dentist told me that it's not an
endorsement not to pay but I got rid of
my canker sores youtube.com slash Tim
cast mr. Poole I hope you keep people
posted and I hope your channel continues
to grow and thrive sir thanks man thanks
for having me absolutely we'll be back
after this I think I have a conquerer
[Music]
if I were the rule of the benevolent
dictator of the world I would legalize
bestiality where you are giving you are
you're pleasuring the animal oh and I
heard there was a debate oh there's no
debate I'm ending the debate I don't
have my gavel with me but nein nein nein
no way no way like how much can a man
withstand a hot girl saying over and
over again I was like i'ma say because
like so there's like was the case that
we covered where there was like a guy or
a girl or something that was pleasuring
a horse and the horse came to a
conclusion right so who got harmed that
looks like the longest time in the world
and right there there's no way I would
hook up with it I think no no no way man
I don't want to find out what's going on
up downstairs
I mean if you really ask the horse did
you mind the answers got to be
I'm jet weigert and I approve this
message right library time let's let's
say you're a firearm owner and I am this
is I can you combine two sponsors
Walther meet FL PFLP Walter Walter
FLP Ione Walters you guys know that and
of course they have some firearms that
aren't Walthers namely shotguns and
ar-15s uh anyway you're a firearm owner
I assume if you're watching the show
which means you probably taking steps to
defend yourself that's great but what do
you do to defend yourself legally if you
have to use your firearm a lot of people
don't even think about this that's where
FLP comes in if you have to use your
firearm and you have to deal with the
fallout FLP has a toll-free number that
you call night or day a representative
will guide you through the critical
moments after you've defended yourself
or your family they have a network of
attorneys ready to help you they help
with everything in dealing with the
authorities to bail to making sure that
you get your firearm back it's like 995
a month to make sure that if you ever
actually have to use the wonderful
firearm that you've invested and
probably customized and tricked out but
you actually have to use it for an
original purpose that you don't get
burned so go to firearms legal.com slash
lwc register now that's FLP at firearms
legal comm /lw see if you have a firearm
and you ever need to protect yourself or
could need to protect yourself and you
don't have this kind of protect you're
an idiot
you're an idiot
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
louder with prouder ranger pants buy
yours today at ladder with prouder shop
cop
[Music]
that was called the Bing and honor of
Bing Crosby beating his children
mercilessly curse your notice this by
the way thank you so much - Tim Poole
thank you this is one of the weeks where
we don't have a web extended interview
for people who are in love club because
his voice was really pretty rough this
is a Bing Crosby signature pipe oh
that's nice you know why what he used to
want to use a Canadian that's called the
Canadian pipe actually this was my
grandfather's pipe so you see how it's
straight stemmed yeah so it's straight
stemmed but the Bing version was a
little bit longer with the curve cuz for
a while he wanted to take all of his
head shots with his pipe and so he
wanted to be further out from his face
and below his like a chin yeah sure sure
do it oh I see yeah and then he was a
monster know if you've read like a bag
of him being cross monster could sing
you know to families right his first
family said he was just a monster that's
horribly abusive father I think all of
his kids from his first marriage killed
themselves or several of them and then
in the second family
they just said he was the best dad ever
that's weird and none of this came out
in Holiday Inn no that was the st.
Mary's I'll ring you like a bell
he's 12 I don't care by the way that
Brennan that reminds me of course next
Wednesday the stream is next Wednesday
our big Christmas show it is live a live
stream where we will actually be in a
studio with 200 people raising money for
Christmas basket it's gonna be a variety
show we'll have not only jokes Christmas
sketches will have singers some surprise
guests Santa Claus will make an
appearance with some children will be
raising some money have a promo code at
discount so if you haven't signed up for
a mailing list it is available in Dallas
Texas exclusively to mug club members
first and the attire is formal we will
be wearing tuxedos we want it to be very
nice and I know you're thinking where's
there a punch line coming no I just
wanted to be a nice cozy Christmas event
with wildly offensive jokes it's next
Wednesday and then we'll be off until
the new year so here's what I wanted to
talk about today a little bit and this
is gonna be tough so if you do have
children in the room right now it asks
that you not that there's anything
inappropriate but but it could be some
disturbing material a little bit a
little bit tough a little bit intense
for kids you know I told you guys that I
wasn't going to
about after hopper you know I had to put
him down last last Friday by the way I
don't know if ever there was a betting
pool out there as to how many days of
work I would miss when hammer passed
so whoever bet half a day you win the
pool you know exact you know exactly who
you are
doesn't bother me I just think it's sad
for you but you did win the cash prize I
wouldn't curious to see what the betting
pool is up to now so I'm not talking so
much right now about for those who think
you can't watch this you'll get choked
up about about hopper so much is the
interaction that occurred between my
wife and I as a husband and I want to do
this for wives maybe next week or maybe
when we come back a show or a close just
exalting wives but right now I want to
speak to what I know two husbands out
there and of course fathers but I'd like
to speak specifically to husbandry
because I think it's something that's
very underappreciated and it's a very
very important role in our society and
one that I've really you know I'm being
married for seven years come to
understand more recently so when we did
we had to go when we had to put hopper
down last week and I can talk about it I
was very very hard his last act of
defiance you'll be happy to know was he
turned his nose up at an American
mackerel log or beer as part of his
final meal he looked to my Belgian
Tripel
like give me that look and I said okay
poured it out drank all of it it's the
very last thing he did was be a diva
beast - thank you copper so this is
something as a husband and hoppers my
first dog and it's a first dog that my
wife and I've ever had together but as a
kid I just dreamed of dogs I've talked
about this before so we were really
really close but it was also really
close with my wife and so not only the
last year because of the lymphoma so
we've had some time you know he was in
remission too to think about how this
would end but really for the entirety of
us owning hopper
I always thought of what would this day
look like I think everyone who owns a
dog thinks about that right because
their life is so much more finite than
ours at least how we view it and I never
wanted to bring it up because I knew how
much it would upset my wife so for years
I would think about it I would go and
sometimes I want to say well what's
wrong cuz I'll be making a face I make
two things she knows what's wrong if I
would make a face where I was really
upset or sad she's like okay is thinking
about hopper if I do this she's thinking
about when I broke my knee because I
relive it and it actually like fit I go
I winced and I grabbed my knee so for a
long time I used to think about it what
it looked like what I would have to do
and how I would protect my wife from it
and I'll tell you I pictured it many
times I knew exactly what I was going to
do is picturing holding hopper when they
put him down
with my arm because he always liked to
lay underneath my right arm right kind
of underneath his neck here his big old
noggin that he had and I would rub his
belly that's kind of what we didn't used
to sit there together and when we went
in we put his bed down and this was it
was it was a very reverent sort of it
wasn't just putting some animal down the
vets who weren't even working that day
technicians came in because he touched a
lot of lives and I appreciate the
sentiments that you've sent in but when
I went in at that point my wife was
already there and I'd picture this at
least a thousand times in my head how
was gonna hold him I was gonna sue them
make sure that I was strong until the
end because the last thing you want to
do is send him out when you're
emotionally unstable but my wife was
there and she was holding him and so it
changed right away - without even
thinking I wasn't holding hopper I was
clutching my wife and it was something
that occurred to me I guess not so much
at the time but afterwards realizing it
I think dogs teach us a lot about how we
interact with people the way we interact
with with dogs often reflects how we
interact with people and something this
situation with hopper would make he made
me a more selfless person in
understanding that other people come
first and at this point I realized that
Hopper was taken care of my wife was
making sure he was taken care of she was
the one who needed to be taken care of
at that but before I move on to to talk
more about sort of being a husband this
is something really bizarre that I've
never experienced before they were
really nice when they went when they put
hopper down they put the put in the the
money called know the anesthesia or
whatever does it puts you under and so
you fall asleep and then they put in
whatever the chemical is maybe that
stops your heart but we didn't know when
the heart had stopped because we were
holding him and trying to kind of
maintain composure this is the most
bizarre thing I think I've ever
experienced we were in a room there were
other dogs there we only knew when I had
gone because the other dogs knew you
ever get some you ever hear silence
that's it's so quiet that
it almost hurts your ears that's what
happened it got so quiet and I looked
over and only when I saw their dogs
sitting up doing the avoidance face and
they started kind of whimpering that's
when I said okay it's it's done it was
just that that's an aside it was a
really weird experience a lot of
learning experiences my wife and I went
to went away for the weekend spend some
time with each other and getting and get
out um but I also I bring this up
because I have a friend a good friend a
good man who the same last week was
going through something I much tougher
um a miscarriage and it was a
miscarriage that was far enough along
the trail that only had to check for a
heartbeat and induce labor and he's been
taking care of his wife for the entire
week afterward because she hasn't been
doing well physically she's been having
some actual physical ramifications that
have required her to be in and out of
the hospital and I know that he I don't
know that his wife knows this but he did
he said the baby was far enough along
that he buried it in the backyard and
put down a flower because this was
important him this wasn't the first time
he had been through this and he
discussed some things with me that his
wife didn't know about that he was
protecting from her and this is
something this goes to the idea of toxic
masculinity let me just kind of state
this in the outset talk we say this all
time the toxic masculine it's okay to
cry men feel that you can't cry but why
can't you just be open with your
emotions why are men so aggressive you
know why because we love our wives if
you love your wife you make sure that
you try to be strong now there's an
appropriate time to cry there's an
appropriate time to grieve with your
wife of course but it's not all the time
at that moment in time I couldn't go on
I had to clutch my wife and make sure
that she was fine at this moment in time
my friend had to be the husband you
don't think he wanted to sit down and
cry you don't think he wanted a moment
for himself and without getting into
specifics because I promised him I
wouldn't every step of the way he was
doing whatever he possibly could for his
wife not for himself that all stems from
toxic masculinity the same reason that
we get angry or the same reason that
we're more aggressive and there are more
Wars is because we fight
them to protect the people that we love
not everyone I get it some husbands are
out to come home and are abusive I'm not
talking about them I'm talking about
husbands who love their families they
will be without a doubt the most toxic
ly masculine people you can imagine and
you know what that is no that's a gift
it's a gift it's the gift that we can
give to women because let's be honest in
most areas women you've got us beat
right if it's if it's the idea of sort
of what's perceived as multitasking you
know some people to leave that to be a
myth right now but let's call it neural
flexibility women can take more sensory
input and deal with it that's why they
make better mothers for that same reason
it's why men tend to why do you think
men make up ninety four ninety seven
percent depending on the source you're
using of workplace deaths did you just
think about that do you think we chose
to line up to be roofing or going to the
coal mine and we want we wanted to make
be that statistic do you think do you
think it's women have been women have
been signing up and they've been
unfairly prejudicial II just know it's a
gift to you because we for the same
reason that women make better mothers we
tend to be task oriented and because of
toxic masculinity we can focus block out
some of the sensory overload and get it
done because that's how we're hardwired
so that we can do it and be stable for
you it's the it's the only gift that we
can give as men at least it's the only
gift that we really think we can give as
men remember when you think about it
this way when you were a kid and he had
issues going on things felt unstable
assuming of course that you have a
decent family I'm not talking to
everyone and I'm that's why it's so
important to me to try and encourage the
family unit and for fathers to own up
there to the responsibilities and be
fathers people say why don't you talk
about a child support and alimony you
know why I get it a lot of guys get a
raw deal but as a man I see a lot of
deadbeat pieces of [ __ ] out there who
don't treat women right and they give
the rest of us a bad name so I try to
focus on making men better sorry you
might be offended men's rights activists
I understand where you're coming from
but this is equally important I want
more debts because remember when you
were a kid and nothing seemed right
everything was unstable you were trying
to find your footing you always thought
okay at least Oh dad's coming in now
he's gonna make it okay
he's going to make it alright guess what
your dad couldn't make it all right all
the time
you know that now was an adult can you
make it all right all the time
no but it's that gift of security of
assurance that you can give to your
children or to your wife as a man as a
head of household that means a lot and
that step and trying to own up to that
expectation that's toxic masculinity
that's not you've heard that line from
as good as it gets what you know women
you make me want to be a better man it's
true women make men want to be better
men better men than our cells show us
how to be better men and and and the
reason that we do a lot of this is
because we ask ourselves how we can
serve we can serve by doing hard jobs
and making up 94 percent of the
workforce we can't serve by making a
casserole we can't serve not all the
time by being as sensitive and as
nurturing as you can and that's why
sometimes when we know that you're more
sensitive and we get that maybe you are
more emotionally inclined and in tune
and someone who's more agreeable and
there's not a lot I can offer in this
situation but I can hold my wife while
we put my dog down you know what maybe
there's not a lot I can necessarily do
around the house but I can make sure
that I lay it on the line that to ensure
that this house is there for my wife
when she gets back and sometimes that
gets us a little bit pissed off
sometimes that gets you know sometimes
we do bottle it in and yeah you feel
like you have razor blades in your
stomach but what is the alternative that
we don't try to live up to any standard
that there's no standard whatsoever for
men you know we've never at by the way
let's talk about this we've never once
asked men will talk about toxic
masculinity for women in the military
it's never come up not because we don't
love you but precisely the opposite
because the whole reason that men would
go into battle and fight wars or the
primary reason I don't want to speak in
absolutes and get fact checked here but
some people will say it's for religion
or war for oil no but a big reason a
primary motivating factor is to protect
our women not send them to the
frontlines why because that's how we
conserve that's how you as a husband
conserve that's as you as a father
consider I'm sure the same applies to
children right we don't we don't have
any we know that we don't have any
children yet and hope we don't have any
children yet so I'll just talk to what I
know as a husband this is important not
only is it important for men to learn
how to be better men but it's important
for you to know how and what it is
you're trying to achieve and what it is
that right now they are trying to tear
down right now the problem I think the
rejection that you are seeing of men who
are trying to better themselves and they
reject this notion of toxic masculinity
is that they are rejecting the removal
of standards that we have held men to
precisely because it's the most
effective and largely the only way that
we can serve and the reason we want to
serve is not because we hate women
not because we're chauvinist but because
we love you that's toxic masculinity for
better or worse you got to take the good
with the bad alright next week
Christmas show on Wednesday we'll see
you then it'll be festive
[Music]